nous recevrons maintenant toujours en
direct sur notre site de l'Assemblée
nationale les représentants de
l'association attaque madame et monsieur
je vous remercie de votre présence
devant la commission d'enquête
aujourd'hui un questionnaire vous a été
préalablement transmis par notre
rapporteur monsieur Florent Boudier les
questions qu'il contient
ne seront pas forcément toutes évoqués
cet après-midi nous vous serions
reconnaissants dans un second temps de
nous transmettre les réponses écrites à
celui-ci alors le point de vue de votre
association intéresse la commission
d'enquête car vous avez été impliqué
dans les manifestations du printemps
contre la réforme des retraites mais
aussi contre les grands projets
agricoles comme par exemple le projet de
sainte Soline vous n'avez jamais appelé
à la violence
mais vous avez eu dans les cortèges pour
voisins des individus qui ne
s'embarrassaient pas faut bien le dire
de ces pudeur d'après les propos que
vous apprêtez la presse madame Yamamoto
vous avez considéré et je me permets de
vous citer les formes d'action sont
complémentaires donc il vous appartient
appartiendra dans un instant d'expliquer
de préciser ce que vous entendez par là
avant de vous faire prêter serment il me
revient donc en quelque sorte d'ouvrir
les débats je le ferai comme d'habitude
en posant deux questions à caractère
plus général première question quelle
est la ligne rouge que vous tracez dans
vos actions en tant qu'attaque et ce le
strict respect de la loi ce qui inclut
la préservation absolue évidemment des
personnes et des biens ou comprenez-vous
que certains sortent du cadre légal pour
poursuivre leur objectif
donc c'est le premier aspect de la
question et le second aspect concerne
donc la suite des manifestations
auxquelles vous avez pris part certains
de vos militants sont-ils entrés dans un
parcours judiciaire donc la situation
elle-même agit-elle en justice donc soit
en demande ou en défense à l'issue des
manifestations du printemps dernier et
quelle expérience en retirez-vous alors
je vais d'ores et déjà vous demander de
prêter serment donc en application de
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance numéro
58-1100 du 17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires je vais vous demander de
prêter serment de dire la vérité toute
la vérité rien que la vérité commencez
par Madame Yamamoto donc si vous pouvez
simplement lever votre main droite et
dire je le jure je le jure
je vous en remercie si vous pouvez voilà
éteindre le micro pour que monsieur gap
puisse faire de même je le jure je vous
en remercie alors juste avant de vous
passer la parole pour que vous puissiez
répondre à ces premières interrogations
je vais aussi passer la parole déjà à
monsieur le rapporteur qui souhaitait
faire un propos liminaire et puis
ensuite je lui repasserai aussi la
parole pour qu'il puisse vous poser à
son tour des questions et puis ensuite
je m'adresserai aussi aux membres de la
commission d'enquête donc s'il souhaite
poser des questions n'hésitez pas chers
collègues à vous manifester donc je vous
remercie et je passe tout de suite la
parole à Monsieur le Rapporteur oui
merci monsieur le Président il n'est pas
d'usage que le rapporteur
interviennent juste après vous mais
plutôt après les intervenants et je vous
remercie de vous être présenté devant la
commission d'enquête je voulais pour la
clarté de nos échanges
évoquer en particulier la communication
que vous avez établie à la date du 23
juin 2023 et qui est disponible au
public pour chacun de nos concitoyens
qui seraient intéressés vous assimilez
la convocation devant la commission
d'enquête parlementaire à une attaque
sans précédent contre la liberté
associative
dans cette même communication vous
assimilez cette convocation je vous cite
à une tentative d'intimidation et de
criminalisation des mouvements sociaux
et écologistes
vous indiquez par ailleurs un
parallélisme avec le retrait de
l'agrément à l'association anticorps
sans citer d'ailleurs quel est le fruit
d'une décision de justice du tribunal
administratif de Paris de 23 juin 2023
et qu'elle n'a évidemment aucun lien
avec cette commission d'enquête de
l'Assemblée nationale composée de
députés vous indiquez par ailleurs que
désormais je vous cite trois autres
associations attaquent par conséquent
instinction rébellion et dernière
rénovation que nous avons auditionné il
y a maintenant deux semaines sont des
sont désormais également donc à
l'identique d'anticorps dans le viseur
étant associé de manière à peine voilée
dites-vous à l'organisation de violence
lors des manifestations et
rassemblements
et vous terminez en disant le
gouvernement semble donc déterminé à
réprimer les mobilisations écologiques
je vous rappelle que vous êtes ici
devant des députés à l'Assemblée
nationale nous ne sommes pas à
l'exécutif et ensuite votre question en
tout cas votre communiqué s'achève par
une question peut-on encore désoberir je
voudrais simplement vous signaler que
votre convocation devant la commission
d'enquête à l'identique d'un très grand
nombre d'acteurs à la fois des
universitaires des journalistes
tous n'étant pas d'accord entre eux des
structures associatives peut-être même
des membres du système politique nous
verrons nous aurons à nous déplacer
monsieur le Président avec l'ensemble
des collègues qui le souhaitent à
Sainte-Souline nous irons également la
semaine prochaine à Bordeaux nous
rencontrerons le maire de Bordeaux qu'on
nous rencontrerons la semaine prochaine
le maire de Bordeaux nous ne considérons
pas que le maire de Bordeaux est
assimilé un groupe muscul violent de la
même façon que nous n'assimilons pas
attaque à un groupe plus sculpture
contrairement à ce que vous écrivez dans
cette communication je croyais que il
était utile on préambule de nos travaux
de pouvoir le signaler parce que
j'imagine que cette communication a été
lu j'imagine qu'elle a été commentée
j'imagine qu'elle a été appréciée
interprétée que les choses soient
claires vous êtes ici parce que vous
avez un éclairage à donner à nos travaux
vous avez une expérience vous avez aussi
une tonalité d'engagement qui est la
vôtre monsieur le Président par ailleurs
a souligné à quel point vous n'appeliez
pas à la violence et les choses sont
tout à fait claires de ce point de vue
nous sommes par contre intéressants
intéressés de voir comment vous
appréhender ces violences comment vous
considérez aussi le climat politique
autour des rassemblements des
manutations comment vous jugez
l'action du gouvernement c'est le même
de la majorité à laquelle j'appartiens
mais ici je suis en tant que rapporteur
donc rapporteur de la commission
d'enquête dans sa pluralité et j'avais
envie de vous poser cette question vous
êtes plutôt encore désobéir mais la
lecture de votre communication et je ne
serai pas plus long monsieur le
Président je me demandais si l'on
pouvait encore débattre
son travestir la réalité car vous
travestissez la réalité dans cette
communication et je me demandais si nous
pouvions faire notre travail de
parlementaire aussi simplement que nous
pouvons le faire c'est à dire en
essayant de nous nourrir des expériences
des uns et des autres des commentaires
des appréciations des contradictions
parfois même des conflits qui opposent
un certain nombre de points de vue dans
la société dans l'hémicycle dans cette
commission et de façon générale dans
notre pays
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
donc je vais évidemment vous passiez la
parole je sais pas quelle d'entre vous
souhaite démarrer mais enfin cette je
vous laisse le soin dans décider
je vous remercie je vais donc introduire
par un propos liminaire et ensuite ce
sera Vincent donc je rappelle ce qui
attaque attaque est une association née
il y a 25 ans qui lutte pour la justice
fiscale écologique et sociale créée à la
suite d'un édito d'ignation ramonais
dans Le Monde diplomatique qui s'appelle
désarmons les marchés financiers en 1998
attaque à des ses origines rassembler
syndicats associations titre de presse
et personnalité par le biais de nos
comités locaux nous sommes présents et
présente sur l'ensemble du territoire
français nous tirons nos ressources des
cotisations de nos adhérentes et
adhérents et des dons de particuliers
nous nous pensons comme un outil au
service des mouvements sociaux en
articulant action réflexions et analyse
par le biais d'ouvrage de rapport ou
encore de notes consacrées au système
économique social et politique auquel
nous nous opposons et aux alternatives
que nous pouvons lui opposer notre
expertise est d'ailleurs reconnue
ce système capitaliste et néolibéral et
producteur d'injustices d'inégalités et
destructeurs du vivant et il nous semble
urgent d'en changer
par nos actions nous cherchons donc à
transformer ce système en résistant aux
politiques en place et en promouvant des
alternatives
notre slogan depuis nos débuts reste le
même un autre monde est possible
nous nous revendiquons de la
désobéissance civile car nous sommes
convaincus qu'il existe des urgences et
un état de nécessité qui légitime d'agir
en dehors du cadre légal pour
transformer ce dernier et le mettre au
service d'impératifs sociaux et
écologique en somme au service du bien
commun
en l'état l'ordre public qu'il faut
protéger devrait d'abord concerner le
vivant les écosystèmes les droits
sociaux la démocratie
en réponse au défaillances de l'État et
à l'inaction gouvernementale l'action
citoyenne et l'émanc central qui
garantit le bon fonctionnement d'un
régime démocratique et plus que
nécessaire notre consensus d'action est
clair nous excluons toute violence qui
s'exerce à l'encontre de personnes en
revanche nos actions peuvent entraîner
des dégradations légères de bien public
ou privés notre association a été
reconnue comme menant des campagnes
d'intérêt général par la justice en 2018
sur le paiement de l'impôt et l'évasion
fiscale et cette décision a légitimé
notre usage de la désobéissance civile
en indiquant que notre action
s'inscrivait dans le cadre de la liberté
d'expression et de manifestation
nous nous revendiquons également de
l'éducation populaire et cherchons à
faire vivre des horizons émancipateurs
nous faisons notre possible pour mettre
en cohérence nos principes tels qu'ils
apparaissent dans nos statuts nous
orientations validées en assemblée
générale et notre fonctionnement que
nous voulons aussi horizontal et
inclusif que possible
et donc pour prendre la suite
effectivement et ça répondra en partie
je pense mais en partie seulement
aux questions de monsieur le rapporteur
on a effectivement été un peu étonné
d'être convoqué de devant cette
commission d'enquête parlementaire et on
s'est demandé en quelle qualité nous
sommes entendus vous avez un peu précisé
les choses mais
la lecture du questionnaire préalable à
cette à cette réunion le doute subsiste
alors est-ce que c'est entre en notre
qualité d'expert mais notre association
ne travaille pas particulièrement sur la
doctrine du maintien de l'or mais donc
il y a des spécialistes bien plus
affûtés pour discuter de ça est-ce que
c'est que en tant que partie prenante du
mouvement social qui couvre notamment
les contestations de la période du 16
mars au 3 mai 2023 à savoir la période
qui intéresse cette commission est-ce
que c'est parce que nous incarnons avec
d'autres une forme d'opposition
politique alors peut-être que
effectivement c'est là que
que la question se pose alors bien sûr
nous assumons ce statut nous nous
opposons au pouvoir actuellement en
place et ce depuis 2017 et d'ailleurs
nous avons publié un livre sur le bilan
du macronisme en 2022 mais au-delà de
notre présence ici c'est surtout les
questions en fait qui nous interrogent
des questions qui nous ont été posées
parce que elle semble relever quand même
d'une suspicion a priori qui s'ajoute à
la longue liste de déclaration de
membres du gouvernement ou ou d'élus qui
traite souvent les manifestations
d'opposition divergentes comme étant
violentes radical extrémiste anti
républicaine voire terroriste l'ensemble
de ce vocabulaire nous sommes pas nous
semble pas correspondre bien entendu à
la réalité et Marc au moins dans le
discours mais on pourra revenir
également dans les faits une grave
dérive autoritaire combattre ces idées
de son opposition par la répression
n'est pas digne un gouvernement qui se
revendique de la démocratie or on
constate quand même depuis un certain
nombre d'années et on aura sans doute
l'occasion d'en parler c'est attesté par
de nombreux rapports que ce soit en
France ou au niveau international on
constate donc une dégradation des
libertés des libertés publiques vous
avez fait référence à certaines
décisions que l'on a mentionnées dans
notre dans notre communication récente
il aurait pu en avoir
beaucoup beaucoup d'autres à tel point
que des personnes aussi respectables que
François Molin c'est à dire l'ex procure
générale près de la Cour de cassation
parle alors il utilise un terme savant
il parle de risque de mithridatisation
face aux restrictions des libertés
publiques qu'est-ce que c'est que la
Mith privatisation c'est le fait
d'ingérer des doses croissantes d'un
produit toxique afin d'acquérir
supposément une insensibilité ou une
résistance vis-à-vis de celui-ci
autrement dit ce qu'il veut dire c'est
que à force de
d'accumuler les mesures liberticides on
risque de s'habituer à cette à cette à
cette restriction
des libertés et nous bien sûr
effectivement on estime que à force de
réduire le périmètre de la démocratie on
tend la main à des tentations
autoritaires François moulin se rappelle
également que l'État de droit se définit
par la garantie des libertés
fondamentales d'expression de
manifestations de réunions et
d'associations et met en garde contre ce
qu'il appelle les procès en
terrorisation de l'action politique et
syndicale l'usage de l'expression
éco-terrorisme par un ministre du
gouvernement est à cet égard pour le
moins inquiétant donc cette commission
d'enquête nous a effectivement inquiété
d'un certain point de vue non pas tant
pour ce qui concerne attaque ni même
finalement les risques on pourrait
courir mais plutôt effectivement par les
préoccupations des parlementaires qui
émanent du questionnaire que nous avons
reçu il y aurait pourtant effectivement
beaucoup à dire sur les violences les
violences qu'on retrouve quotidiennement
dans la société par exemple les
violences commises contre les migrants
qui fuient leur pays quand ils arrivent
en ou quand ils meurent en Méditerranée
ou dans la Manche les violences
sexuelles et sexistes qui touchent les
femmes au travail ou dans leur domicile
ou qui touchent également les minorités
sexuelles les violences qui touchent les
populations les plus pauvres qui ont
réduit les allocations chômage et qui ne
retrouvent plus dans l'état social les
moyens d'être protégés les violences qui
touchent les jeunes des quartiers
populaires ou encore les violences qui
touchent le vivant
à cause du productivisme et de
l'agro-industrie donc on nous on aurait
été tout à fait favorable à parler des
violences mais la liste de ces violences
est sans doute bien trop longue et une
commission parlementaire ni suffirait
pas mais puisque aujourd'hui nous avons
été convoqués bien sûr nous sommes prêts
à répondre à vos questions
très bien je vous remercie est-ce que
Madame il y avait autour vous lis encore
intervenir ou
non ça va je vous remercie très bien
alors simplement avant de passer la
parole à Monsieur le rapporteur je
voudrais insister sur plusieurs points
pour qu'il n'y ait pas la moindre
ambiguïté une commission d'enquête
parlementaire a pour objectif de d'avoir
des échanges avec un grand nombre à la
fois d'organisation et de représentants
à la fois d'organisation et
d'institutions d'ailleurs aussi bien
public que que privé et en réalité pour
pour nous il y a une claire séparation
des pouvoirs vous êtes ici dans
l'enceinte du pouvoir législatif et
justement notre notre rôle est aussi
d'assurer un contrôle du pouvoir
exécutif donc à cet égard nous ne sommes
nullement je dirais à superposer avec
avec le pouvoir exécutif sont deux
choses de nature de nature tout à fait
différente concernant le point que que
vous évoquez c'est à dire celui de de
l'usage de la désobéissance civique
est-ce que vous vous pourriez revenir
sur sur ce point dans la mesure où c'est
évidemment un point qui aujourd'hui est
aussi utilisé et comment dire on voit un
certain nombre de protagonistes
utilisés de le terme de désobéissance
civique tout en le faisant coexister
avec des actions susceptibles d'être
violentes donc quel est votre position
en tant qu'attaque à cet égard dans la
mesure où justement quand on regarde
historiquement ce mouvement de la
désobéissance civique et plus
précisément enfin si on prend l'une je
dirais des figures emblématiques de ce
mouvement comme Rosa Parks elle
insistait sur le fait que par nature
l'action avait vocation à être non
violente c'est-à-dire que il y avait
bien entendu une volonté d'une
affirmation politique mais que cette
affirmation politique et la légitimité
de je dirais du principe même
désobéissance civique et est associé à
la non-violence
nous semblons
voir de plus en plus un glissement vers
une coexistence entre le concept de
désobéissance civique d'une part et
celui du recours à la violence est-ce
que il y a une position d'attaque ou pas
à cette à cet égard
là effectivement dans l'objet social de
l'association l'action fait partie
l'action fait partie de des missions de
notre association et notamment nous
assumons l'usage de la désobéissance
civile bon bah vous avez cité Rosa Park
effectivement mais fait quand on
s'appuie sur l'histoire des luttes des
mouvements sociaux et des conquis
sociaux la désobéissance civile est un
outil de l'opposition politique pour
porter la transformation sociale
et sur nous nous revendiquons en fait de
la désobéissance civile on s'appuie sur
sur la légitimité internationale de ce
mode d'action et dans les actions que
nous portons le consensus de nos
violences et la base et le cœur et le
moteur notamment pour donner une grande
visibilité à nos revendications voilà on
souhaite avoir un impact particulier et
on est sur une ligne de crête entre la
légitimité la légalité nous
transgressons volontairement la légalité
mais dans un avec une cible précise avec
des méthodes précises pour que cela ne
dénature pas et ne décrédibilise pas le
message politique que l'on porte
je vous remercie pour cette précision
monsieur gay vous souhaitez quelque
chose je pense que effectivement
l'utilisation des débats historiques et
importantes et on voit que c'est des
débats encore très contemporains on a vu
récemment une
présidente de région vouloir des
baptiser le nom d'un collège Angela
Davis en Seine-Saint-Denis donc c'est
encore des questions qui sont pas du
tout refroidies et je crois que
effectivement il y a une lecture un peu
un peu rapide de cette désobéissance
civile qui a été relativement porté au
nu parce qu'elle l'aurait été
consensuelle aux États-Unis avec le
mouvement des droits civiques en réalité
les choses ont été beaucoup plus
complexes que ça puisque effectivement
dans le mouvement pour les droits civils
pour l'égalité entre les entre les entre
les noirs et les blancs aux États-Unis
l'articulation des différents mouvements
des différentes tactiques des
différentes pratiques a toujours été un
débat permanent conflictuel parfois et
ça l'est toujours ça l'est également
aujourd'hui dans les mouvements sociaux
en France mais aussi
d'alliance ponctuelle ou ou plus durable
donc on n'a pas d'un côté la bonne
désobéissance civile qui serait
strictement non violente et une période
où on se réfère à celle-ci et de l'autre
côté et très très loin des actions qui
seraient qui seraient autre je crois que
les choses sont beaucoup plus complexes
que ça et c'est dans cette situation OK
dans laquelle on agit aujourd'hui tout
comme le mouvement des suffragettes en
Angleterre au début du du 20e siècle a
démontré des pratiques qui aujourd'hui
sont légitimées par la
cause qu'elle défendait mais qui à
l'époque apparaissait comme étant le
fait de de harpie et de sauvageonne donc
je crois que voilà si on veut vraiment
discuter
à partir d'exemples historiques il faut
essayer de prendre en considération
l'ensemble des des événements qui qui
sont qui se sont arrivés pour nous j'en
arrêterai là une peut-être une des
importances qu'on met à nos actions
c'est que on souhaite qu'elle soit
massivement portée par des citoyens et
des citoyens c'est à dire qu'on ne se
renferme pas dans des actions minorités
isolées qu'on ferait simplement pour
défendre notre propre cause mais qu'on
veut on tente toujours à construire de
l'immobilisation les plus massives
possibles et ça bien sûr ça implique
quand même aussi un certain rapport à la
à la non-violence puisque effectivement
toute une série de personnes à la juste
titre dans la population bien sûr
souhaite agir mais en toute sécurité
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
je vous passe la parole
oui merci monsieur le Président on est
vraiment au cœur du sujet parce que
vous prenez mal la convocation mais moi
je trouve la vous remarques très
intéressantes et peut-être que l'échange
le sera aussi
vous êtes dans une logique en tout cas
telle que vous la présentez si je
comprends bien
c'est violent se trouve violence
la violence civile
de la société ou de citoyens mobilisés
répond à une forme de violence d'État
que vous avez caractérisé à la fois
social économique et voir privative de
liberté donc on comprend bien dans quel
logique vous êtes c'est dans une logique
de violence contre violence moi ce que
je ce que je voudrais comprendre c'est
1 est-ce que vous considérez parce que
nous ne sommes pas un Isola ni en Europe
ni dans le monde est-ce que vous
considérez
qu'il y a un niveau de conflictualité
particuliers à la France et ce que nous
étudions nous ce sont les violences
commises à l'occasion de rassemblement
de manifestations ce ne sont pas les
manifestants eux-mêmes ni même les
structures qu'il est soutiennent
est-ce que vous considérez qu'il y a un
niveau de conflictualité propre à la
France
est-ce que vous considérez donc il y a
un niveau de conflictualité propre à la
France comment vous situez par rapport à
cette montée je n'aime pas le terme de
radicalité politique je n'aime pas le
terme parce qu'il est mis à toutes les
sauces mais je l'emploi parce qu'il est
c'est une facilité de langage première
question et deuxième question
vous parler de non-violence et en même
temps vous assumez des dégradations
matérielles légères ou limitées je ne
sais plus que précisément le terme que
vous avez employé et dans une dans un
article du Point qui date du 5 avril
vous répétiez en effet madame Yamamoto
votre opposition à toute forme de
violence menaçant l'intégrité physique
d'une personne effectivement vous ne
rejetiez pas la possibilité d'un certain
nombre de dégradation matérielle donc
comment un vous vous situez comment vous
appréhender comment vous analysez
le niveau de conflictualité qui semble
plus important en France qu'autrefois
dans la façon dont le débat y compris
politique se déroule et deuxièmement
quelle est la frontière de la
non-violence parce que vous avez
beaucoup parlé de non-violence tout en
assumant et dégradation matérielle
dégradation matérielle ça n'est pas une
violence au sens pénal du terme on est
d'accord
ça n'est pas non plus un acte Pacifique
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
donc je vous repasse la parole alors sur
la comparaison par rapport à d'autres
pays ça dépend quel
spectre géographique constitue je pense
que toute une série et de d'éléments
dans les la dernière décennie montre que
les révoltes ont été extrêmement
extrêmement violente alors voilà
j'imagine que c'est peut-être pas à
celle-ci que vous pensez mais si on
reprend les révolutions arabes le début
de la révolution en Syrie le mouvement
de maïdan en Ukraine etc on voit que la
France n'est pas du tout comment dire
un cas isolé dans ce qui serait oui
donc vous vous considérez que la France
est à l'équivalent de notre pays arabe
donc je pense que la France n'est pas un
cas isolé si en tout cas le pays où la
radicalité ou la violence politique
serait serait la plus forte bien au
contraire justement je considère que on
en est loin et
on peut l'expliquer par du fait diverses
façons mais notamment par la vieille
histoire démocratique de de la
République française qui fait que bien
sûr il y a un certain nombre de
garde-fous
d'institutions qui
préserve plus que plus que dans certains
pays mais pas dans tous les les libertés
publiques mais à ce à ce compte là toute
une série de d'éléments tant de ta
pensée que la situation se dégrade
c'est-à-dire que on a eu plusieurs
affaires qui ont montré que les libertés
publiques notamment associatives étaient
attaquée alors on sera bien sûr pas
d'accord sur le bilan qu'on fait de la
loi
dites séparatisme préservant les
principes républicain mais qui nous
semble être notamment marquée par un
désir de contrôle et de suspicion a
priori des manifester des associations
qui a quand même conduit par exemple des
préfectures à vouloir enlever des
subventions à certaines associations au
prétexte qu'elles organisaient des
ateliers donc des débats sur la
désobéissance civile et puis que le
phénomène quand même sur lequel tout le
monde s'est alerté depuis quelques
années c'est bien sûr la question des
violences policières on constate
nous mais avec plein d'autres personnes
que ce phénomène là c'est radicalisé
alors à partir de quand souvent en date
de les choses de 2016 qui est sûr c'est
que les procédures qui ont été utilisées
dans le cadre de l'état d'urgence face
au terrorisme de 2015 ont été réutilisés
et réemployés pour traiter des
camilitants des 2015 avec effectivement
le le contrôle de militants et leur et
le fait de les de les obliger à à rester
à rester chez eux et être contrôlé mais
bien sûr alors on va pas revenir
longuement sur les sur les chiffres je
pense qu'on a pas forcément le temps et
toutes les études sur ce qui s'est passé
en 2016 au moment de la loi travail au
moment bien sûr du mouvement des gilets
jaunes avec quand même 860 cas vérifiés
documenté de violence policiers entre
des sondes 2018 et juin 2019 montre que
les pratiques policières ont sans doute
aussi connu une certaine une certaine
évolution
l'autre évolution qui a été aussi
marquante c'est l'utilisation de plus en
plus
rapide et évidente d'un certain nombre
de d'armes de manière offensive de la
part des forces de l'ordre de contact
avec les manifestants il y avait une
question dans le que nous avions envoyé
sur est-ce que on pense que les les
pratiques actuelles du maintien de
l'Orne
vont dans le sens de limiter les
contacts on voit bien sûr que que ce
n'est pas le cas et plusieurs
institutions avec lesquelles on n'a pas
spécialement de liens par exemple une
Nations unies ou le Conseil de l'Europe
ce sont inquiétés de l'usage excessif du
recours à la force et du fait que ce
recours excessif faisait peser des
risques sur les libertés publiques un
dernier chiffre avant de passer la
parole à Yuli sur le sur le mouvement
des gilets jaunes on a quand même
comptabilisé 30000 personnes blessées
par le maintien de l'ordre 30 personnes
et borniers 5 personnes avec une main
arrachée et une personne qui n'aime
Redouane qui est décédée après avoir été
heurté par une grenade lacrymogène à
Marseille alors qu'elle n'était même pas
manifestante donc oui bien sûr que il y
a un problème de ce côté là
oui en fait pour situer le niveau de
conflictualité je pense qu'il faut quand
même
savoir entendre
les alertes
au niveau national donc que ce soit la
Défenseur des droits ou la contre le
général de privation de liberté comme
les alertes à l'international donc que
ce soit par les experts expertes de
l'ONU donc il y a voilà globalement il y
a une remise en question de la politique
du maintien de l'ordre d'enfance il y a
des alertes sur les violences policières
et il y a il y a un besoin de remettre
en question profondément le chemin le
schéma de maintien de l'ordre parce que
comme Vincent l'a évoqué donc elle
recensé les différents mouvements
sociaux etc on est quand même dans une
situation politique
de crise qui qui crée des
avec une politique ouverte
gouvernementale qui qui oblige les
mouvements sociaux à se mobiliser donc
les mouvements sociaux ne continuent en
fait de se mobiliser mon passe se calmer
vu le contexte de crise que traverse la
France et pour répondre à cela depuis
2017 on constate que il y a une
augmentation
des lois sécuritaires donc bon elles ont
été évoquées elles ont été évoquées je
vais peut-être pas toutes les mais
depuis 2017 il y a une augmentation très
importante des lois sécuritaires et un
dispositif de maintien de l'ordre qui
est très offensif qui est reconnu comme
étant
étant source de tension de violence et
de brutalité et par exemple pour
pour
ce qui est questionné ici c'est un usage
proportionné ou pas de la force en fait
s'il y a une réponse comme ça s'il y a
autant de tension et de conflictualité
c'est aussi parce que le schéma ne
correspond pas et ne répond pas à la
situation particulière de la
contestation politique en France et
globalement il y a un problème de de
respect de l'opposition politique donc
que ce soit par les lois sécuritaires
par le schéma du maintien de l'ordre
mais il n'y a pas de possibilités pour
l'opposition politique de s'exprimer de
manière
audible donc la réponse elle est
nécessairement en conflictualité et
peut-être que la France déjà devrait
entendre les tous les différents
rapports que ce soit français ou
internationaux mais aussi s'inspirer
d'autres schémas du maintien de l'ordre
que ce soit par exemple la politique du
maintien de l'ordre en Allemagne a
décidé à partir de
de
1985 il y a une décision
constitutionnelle de que la police aille
au contact au dialogue pour pour entamer
une politique donc de désescalade et ça
c'est pratique donc depuis des 1985 ça a
largement inspiré d'autres pays
européens et donc dans les
manifestations du 1er mai par exemple en
Allemagne il y a des tiers de mortier il
y a des conflictualités corps à corps et
des violences très fortes et pourtant
ils pratiquent cette politique de
désescalade qui fonctionne et qui
arrivent à faire baisser un niveau de
tension de manière très importante or la
réponse actuelle en France c'est
d'augmenter les dispositifs de
répression que ce soit par les
techniques qui sont pratiquées que ce
soit par les armes qui sont utilisées
donc il y a des grenades qui sont
classifiées armes de guerre voilà il y a
par exemple des grenades où il y a
l'obligation de les tirer en cloche
c'est le gm2l et elles ne sont là déjà
un
une étude qui a démontré qu'elles
étaient malheureusement insuffisamment
tirées en cloche et provoquer trop de
blessures donc que ce soit dans dans les
méthodes dans les outils dans
la politique et la législation il y a
globalement une réponse
répressive qui est indisproport qui est
indiscriminé et disproportionné face à
l'opposition politique et il faut savoir
entendre les alertes internes comme
internationales pour remettre en
question profondément cette politique de
répression
oui simplement alors je précise quand
même pour celles et ceux qui nous
regardent les quelques-uns qui suivent
en direct sur le site de l'Assemblée
nationale nos travaux de la commission
la loi séparatisme j'en étais le
rapporteur général ce qui va pas
améliorer nos relations si je dois dire
je plaisante bien sûr la loi séparatisme
elle n'a pas instauré un contrôle a
priori des structures associatifs pas du
tout elle permet par contre dans le cas
du non-respect du contrat d'engagement
républicain que chaque association doit
signer si elle le souhaite à posteriori
de sa déclaration préfecture évidemment
la déclaration se fait tout à fait
légitimement elle peut aboutir un
certain nombre de privations de
subventions publiques et je vous le dis
là par contre c'est mon avis personnel
mais je maintiens en tout cas celui que
j'ai pu avoir en tant que rapporteur à
l'époque
considérer que une collectivité locale
que le financement public
n'est pas forcément nécessaire pour
organiser la désobérance des obéissance
civile je trouve pas ça choquant que
l'argent public ne servent pas à
financer
la structurer la désobéissance civile
l'association en tant que tel elle
existe elle n'est pas privée de son
existence simplement l'état dit à un
moment donné écoutez on va peut-être pas
financer y compris des ateliers des
obéissance civile peut-être pas quand
même peut-être pas pousser la liberté
associative jusque là mais pas répondu
par contre sur la frontière la ligne de
Crète je reprends vos propos entre
violence et non violences moi je crois
que c'est très important parce que il y
a un certain nombre d'interprétation je
ne dis pas que c'est la mienne il y a un
certain nombre d'interprétations qui
considère qu'au fond on arrive dans une
situation de continuum de violence
violence
un mot très nuageux à tiroir animé tout
et rien à la fois que au fond il y a un
espèce de chaîne de raisonnement qui va
de la tolérance à la citation jusqu'à la
violence matérielle puis éventuellement
le passage à l'acte vers la violence et
personne donc j'aurais bien voulu vous
répondiez à ma question précédente sur
violence non violence et notamment je
notais ce que moi j'estime être une
contradiction mais c'est à vous de me
répondre bien sûr entre le fait que vous
affichez
non violent et qu'en même temps vous
acceptez des dégradations matérielles je
reprends le terme que vous avez après
tout à l'heure limiter ou légère je ne
sais plus précisément merci monsieur le
rapporteur donc monsieur gay je vous en
prie oui juste un tout petit détail
effectivement je reviens juste sur ce
que vous venez de dire la question n'est
pas de
mettre fin des associations mais faire
peser quand même sur elle une forme de
regard de l'état sur son sur leur choix
et je pense que ça c'est effectivement
une intrusion anti-démocratique sur la
vie des associations c'est à dire qu'en
fait on conditionne quand même les
subventions qui font quand même vivre
beaucoup les associations en France à ce
qu'elles font une font pas par ailleurs
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que des
associations ont été dissoutes qui
n'étaient pas dans la dissolution est
quand même
c'est un autre sujet mais pas
complètement parce qu'en fait on l'a
mentionné un certain nombre d'attaques
contre la vie associative je
mentionnerai un cas et je parlerai même
pas des soulèvements de la terre ici
enfin pas tout de suite peut-être mais
le cas du collectif contre
l'islamophobie en France qui défendait
juridiquement des musulmans qui se
sentaient à Torro a raison discriminés
bon cette association a été a été
dissoute donc la suspicion contre
l'action militante contre l'action
associative nous semble être une donnée
de la situation présente ensuite bon sur
le continent sur la question du
continuum des violences et et où sont où
passent les frontières nous ce qu'on
peut vous dire en tant qu'association
qui se dénomata c'est que nous nous
procédons pas à des violences bien sûr
contre les personnes comme vous comme
nous l'avons dit et donc le fait qu'on
nous réclamons de cette de cette non
violence pour autant effectivement il
nous semble assez peu assez peu on va
dire dommageable notamment pour des
grandes entreprises de voir quelques
équipements effectivement légèrement
abîmés parce que c'est un des rares
moyens de protestation qu'on a c'est à
dire que
une affaire qui a fait beaucoup parler
autour de l'entreprise Lafarge donc par
ailleurs condamné quand même pour ces
malversations avec l'État islamique bon
effectivement non ça ne pose pas
spécialement de problèmes que les les
lieux de travail enfin les
entreprises Lafarge soit légèrement
dégradées bon en général en fait les
dégradations sont très très symbolique
c'est souvent des tags des peintures des
fois quelques petites des quelques
petites destructions qui empêchera
rarement l'entreprise de continuer à
produire or par contre ce que ces
actions permettent c'est de mettre la
lumière sur ce que fait une entreprise
comme Lafarge est-ce que il y a quelques
mois on pouvait mesurer que la question
de du béton la question de
l'exploitation du sable etc était un
grave problème écologique est-ce que on
savait que la gestion de l'eau et la
quête parement par une minorité de
l'agro industrie était aussi
problématique non on ne savait pas et
bien ces actions effectivement de
désobéissance de désobéissance civile
qui certes peuvent s'en prendre des fois
à des biens matériels mais je le redis
mais ça c'est pas des dégradations qui
vont amputer largement l'activité de ces
entreprises et bien effectivement ça
nous semble un moyen parmi d'autres et
puis après il y a bien sûr des effets de
c'est à dire que nous on s'engage pas
dans des choses dangereuses pour les
personnes pour les individus et on en
reste bien sûr dans certaines limites
donc c'est pour ça que moi cette idée de
continuum je n'ai pas de d'avis sur la
question mais par contre je suis
persuadé que ces formes de désobéissance
civile on ont une fonction aujourd'hui
dans la mesure où elles font ce que ne
font pas les autorités à savoir
effectivement
désigner la source d'un certain nombre
de problèmes aujourd'hui
je vous remercie juste un élément
ment
ce que vous évoquiez le cas des
dissolutions d'associations pour qu'on
ait bien un repère
on estime aujourd'hui en France le
nombre d'associations et de l'ordre de
d'un million 500 000 associations si
vous prenez les solutions on a là aussi
un certain nombre de chiffres puisqu'en
fait ces dissolutions passent par des
décrets en fait entre 1936 et 2023 on
est à une centaine de décret de
dissolution donc voyez centaines d'un
côté un million 500 mille de l'autre
donc et puis ensuite très précisément
lorsque l'on étudie les modalités
puisque c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement encadré la loi justement par
la loi pour permettre la liberté
d'associations il doit y avoir une
motivation très précise dans le décret
d'ailleurs certaines associations et
bien engagent d'ailleurs parfois des
recours et donc en fait la motivation
c'est soit l'objet de l'association
elle-même est considérée comme illégal
ou alors les associations ont des
activités qui elles-mêmes sont
contraires aux lois de la République
donc voilà ça me semble quand même
important de préciser cela parce que
parfois on nous effectivement on entend
ces questions dissolution mais elle sont
faut bien le rappeler en plusieurs
décennies relativement peu nombreuses eu
égard je dirais au nombre très très
conséquent d'associations que nous avons
alors je vais tout de suite passer la
parole à Wims
acceptable mais je dois écrire un truc
après je vous rappelle cher collègue qui
s'appelle un rapport juste sur le
sur la question des groupes muscules
violents parce que c'est notre sujet en
fait notre sujet encore une fois c'est
pas attaque ce sont les groupes
musculans donc les groupuscules violents
lorsque nous interrogeons un certain
nombre de d'acteurs y compris du
renseignement c'est vous dire si nous
considérons pas que les renseignements
qui ont été convoqués dans la commission
d'enquête à partir de beaucoup plus
violents
lorsque nous interrogeons il parle
d'ultra gauche
ultra gauche je dis bien extrême gauche
il parle d'ultra jaune il parle
d'individus qui parfois par opportunité
ou dans ce parc de d'emporter par un
phénomène
conjoncturel spontané participe à des
violences dégradations matérielles ou
actes très violents à l'encontre des
forces de l'ordre comment vous
appréhendez cette situation là on est on
est plus dans le continuum ou pas on
n'est plus dans Non Violence dégradation
matérielles vous concernant etc bon on
est vraiment sur vous êtes dans une
manifestation il y a un pré-corpège ce
prix cortège fait entre quelques
centaines de personnes voire quelques
milliers il y a eu pendant la séquence
des retraites et nous-mêmes commençons
notre travail après le 49-3 c'est dire
si nous avons conscience dans un certain
nombre de choses
15.000 personnes dans certaines
manifestations dans le pré-corpège donc
là des personnes qui ne veulent pas être
dans le carré syndical qui cherchent à
échapper une forme
d'institutionnalisation de la
contestation et qui donc vont dans un
lieu précortais-je qui est infiltré par
des individus qui sont notoirement
violents et qui d'ailleurs dont
l'objectif est de faire en sorte que la
manifestation dérape qu'elle se passe
mal et donc il y a une forme à la fois
me semble-t-il d'entrisme et de
déviation de l'objectif de la
manifestation comment vous appréhender
ces éléments là
est-ce qu'il fait partie de vos
préoccupations
de les éviter c'est-à-dire de
les prévenir et si oui de quelle façon
est-ce que c'est impossible et de façon
générale je le répète comment vous
appréhender cette situation là qui est
pour nous le cœur de cible je le
rappelle pour celles et ceux qui nous
écoutent
merci Monsieur rapporteur donc
on peut pas est-ce que Madame Yamamoto
souhaite intervenir oui je vous passe la
parole
je dois rappeler que
nous effectivement notre association est
en une association de transformation
sociale nous nous présentons comme un
outil au service du mouvement social ça
veut dire que l'association s'implique
dans les manifestations et effectivement
par exemple dans le cadre des
manifestations retraite nous avons été
présents et présente avec de nombreux
cortèges dans toutes les manifestations
ce qui veut dire qu'on a une expérience
certaine de comment se déroule
manifestation et de comment arrive les
affrontements des violences déjà
nous comme on l'appréhende c'est qu'on
est tenu de se protéger parce que il y a
des dispositifs policiers qui sont
extrêmement
offensifs et invasif il y a un usage
très important de gaz lacrymogènes il y
a des techniques qui
déstabilisent les foules et
et il y a aussi des méthodes de
déploiement à la fois des techniques
mais aussi des des armes utilisées qui
sont qui sont déployés de manière
indiscriminée et disproportionnée donc
nous comment on organise nos cortèges
c'est en considération de ces de ces
politiques de maintien de l'ordre
et
on nous nous organisons pour en fait
contrevenir à cela mais c'est surtout
cela qui
nous
oblige à nous organiser sur le sur ce
que vous dites en fait
on ne peut enfin vous parler de des
personnes qui sont devant dans en
manifestation
[Musique]
oui donc voilà nous c'est notre priorité
c'est de
permettre à nos militants et militantes
de manifester dans de bonnes conditions
on crée les conditions pour et on
s'organise pour reste que nous avons
constaté depuis 2019 on va 2016 pardon
que les manifestations sont de plus en
plus
[Musique]
sévèrement réprimé en fait c'est surtout
ça c'est que
on a bien compris vous l'avez déjà dit
je pense que c'est bien noté j'en ferai
part ou quoi aucune ambiguïté là je
parle de la façon dont vous jugez
interprétez
observer ces groupuscules notoirement
violent encore une fois je ne parle pas
de la réplique policière de la
disproportion je parle d'individus qui
viennent infiltrer les prix courtage les
manifestations qui ne sont pas là pour
manifester qui ne sont même pas là en
dehors du cortège syndical pour dire
qu'ils ne sont pas dans
l'institutionnalisation de la
constatation sociale mais qui sont là
véritablement pour casser qui sont
organisés nous avons vu que c'est envoyé
des messages que parfois il y a des vols
dans des Décathlon pardon pour de citer
cette cette marque monsieur le Président
d'un certain nombre de matériels en
comment dire en anticipation de
participation voilà je parle de ça
comment vous le jugez comment vous
l'appréhendez
comment vous l’interprétez
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de il y
aurait beaucoup de choses à dire il y a
une série d'enquêtes qui ont été qui ont
été menées sur sur le sujet je pense que
ça relève de plusieurs phénomènes de ne
pas effectivement
la
diminution de capacité d'encadrement des
forces traditionnelles de contestation
en tout cas d'organisation collective
notamment notamment syndical mais aussi
effectivement
le fait que
cette cette stratégie où les pratiques
que vous écrivez s'inscrivent aussi dans
un sentiment un peu généralisé que
bon le pouvoir étant ce qu'il est et ne
répondant pas aux demandes de d'une
partie de la population
il apparaît sinon légitime du moins pas
étonnant que les formes telles que vous
les décrivez apparaissent c'est à dire
que il y a une question quand même qui
est surprenante c'est enfin moi et qui
m'a surpris compris en tant que que
militant depuis un certain nombre
d'années c'est que bien sûr ces
violences que vous décrivez elle elles
existent alors je pense qu'il faut
relativiser
à dire la lecture policière de groupe
qui serait très important et très
infiltré pour vraiment avoir des une
visée telle que vous l'avez décrite on a
vu quand même des affaires de ce type là
qui se sont dégonflés devant la justice
ces dernières années mais pour autant ce
qui serait ce qui doit nous questionner
enfin et vous également je pense c'est
pourquoi ces pratiques là ne sont pas
plus dénoncées que ça par les
manifestations on va dire traditionnels
normaux c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
aujourd'hui effectivement il se commet
un certain nombre de d'actes de
dégradation dans les manifestations
peut-être que il y a un certain nombre
d'années ces gens là auraient été
dénoncés comme étant décaisseurs par la
grande grande majorité des manifestants
mais ce n'est pas le cas pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce que des vous reprenez
cette expression il me semble un peu
d'ultra jaune la qui me semble ne
correspondent pas à grand chose mais en
tout cas effectivement c'est la
catégorie employée par les
renseignements généraux pourquoi est-ce
que des gens on va dire dans le profil
politique sociologique
en gros ressemble finalement à la
plupart des habitants des classes
populaires de notre pays pourquoi à un
moment donné il se passe qui s'est passé
pourquoi il y a cette pratique à un
moment donné de gens qui ne sont pas du
tout d'ultra gauche qui ne sont pas du
tout marqués par une idéologie qui
peut-être rêverait d'insurrection et
pourtant effectivement ils en viennent à
commettre ces actes que vous que vous
décriez pourquoi est-ce que dans la
séquence récente ce qui s'est passé
la multiplication de ces actes là a
commencé à partir du 49-3 pourquoi pas
au début du mouvement c'est bien qu'il y
a cette violence comme vous l'appelez
elle est pas elle ne sort pas nulle part
c'est pas ces gens-là existaient au mois
de janvier ils existaient dès les
premières manifestations pourtant il
n'agissait pas comme ça et surtout en
fait d'autres gens ne reprenaient pas de
tels donc moi je n'ai pas
de regard et je pense que en tout cas
c'est extrêmement compliqué d'avoir un
avis bien déterminé sur les individus
que vous évoquez
par contre ce qui m'interroge c'est
effectivement pourquoi est-ce que leurs
actes ne sont pas couverts d'eau propre
par l'ensemble des manifestants voire
parfois il leur arrive d'être
relativement soutenu ou applaudi en tout
cas certainement pas condamné
merci beaucoup monsieur gay
madame Assimil je vous passe la parole
puis ensuite madame Marceau merci
monsieur le Président alors monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez fait des propos
liminaires et je voulais juste peut-être
rebondir dessus parce que moi-même je
suis assez surprise des fois du contexte
dans lequel nous évoluons et je peux
comprendre l'inquiétude de mouvement
associatifs de lutte pour le climat leur
inquiétude justement d'être convoquée à
une commission d'enquête comme celle-ci
vous dites que la commission d'enquête
n'est pas une commission d'enquête
politique pourtant c'est bien ce qu'elle
est c'est à dire que c'est un choix de
député d'une majorité de mener une
commission d'enquête et c'est un choix
politique ici nous ont de la politique
donc ce sont bien des rapports de force
qui s'expriment vous en êtes le
rapporteur mais vous représentez une
majorité mais non mais dans la cadre de
l'assemblée nationale c'est pour dire
que rien n'est neutre et tout tout un
débat politique je comprends
l'inquiétude des associations dans un
contexte particulièrement dangereux
glissant au niveau des libertés
publiques et d'expression nous-mêmes
députés nous sommes aujourd'hui
assez de sanctions pour participer à des
manifestations alors tout ça enfin voilà
c'était pour réagir à vos propos
liminaires moi j'avais une question et
vous venez d'ailleurs d'y répondre dans
la dernière réponse c'est qu'est-ce qui
fait que aujourd'hui nous en sommes là
et je voulais savoir si vous faisiez le
lien comme nous le faisons de l'impasse
démocratique savoir que la date
effectivement du début de cette
commission d'enquête correspond à la
date du 49-3 et donc d'une réaction
différente du mouvement social dans son
dans son ensemble et la commission
d'enquête concerne aussi les événements
qui se sont déroulés à sainte-soly mais
pour rappel les revendications des
collectifs appelant à Sainte Soline sont
un moratoire sur la question des méga
bassines pas l'interdiction mais un
débat citoyen pour avoir justement une
vision démocratique de cet enjeu et donc
je voulais savoir s'il faut faisiez le
lien justement avec les événements que
nous sommes censés étudier avec les
impasses démocratiques les restrictions
de liberté de plus en plus courantes
dans notre pays notamment les
interdictions de manifester qui se
multiplient avec
des alertes vous en avez parlé de de à
l'international et la question
aujourd'hui de pouvoir exercer des
contre-pouvoirs dans des moments
d'impact démocratique donc je voulais
savoir si vous faites vous faisiez cette
analyse là
très bien je vous remercie donc je vous
repasse la parole madame miamamoto
monsieur gay oui on est vraiment là on
est dans la continuité de l'échange mais
effectivement c'est il faut
effectivement pas analyser enfin se
focaliser sur ce qu'il se passe
concrètement donc sur le terrain mais
voir effectivement les causes et nous
sommes dans un climat très alertant au
niveau des attaques sur nos libertés
publiques donc là actuellement on est on
peut le dire nous sommes dans une crise
démocratique sans précédent parce que il
y a un durcissement législatif très
important qui apporte des atteintes aux
libertés publiques mais parce qu'il y a
aussi un durcissement donc de la
politique du maintien de l'ordre et et
un gouvernement qui
ne n'entend pas l'opposition politique
pour le cas de la réforme des retraites
on voit bien effectivement on parle du
49-3 c'est parce qu'il y a eu des
millions et des millions de personnes
dans la rue il y a eu un rejet de 94%
des actifs etc donc donc c'est ce qui
pousse effectivement à cela mais sur
pourquoi pourquoi nous en sommes en fait
là aujourd'hui c'est la capacité pour
l'opposition politique de proposer des
alternatives actuellement le la
répression est-elle et à plusieurs
endroits et notamment pour le cas de
manifester et bien
quand il y a une multiplication des
arrestations arbitraires et des gardes à
vue ça a été le cas pour la
manifestation du 16 mars il y a eu plus
de 96% des gardes à vue qui ont été
classés sans suite donc les personnes
ont été empêchées de d'exprimer de
d'exercer leur liberté d'expression et
de manifestation si on associe cela aux
arrêtés d'interdiction de manifestation
qui a ensuite ont été annulés par le
tribunal mais pendant ce temps là on est
en incapacité d'exercer notre notre
opposition politique donc d'une manière
générale les dispositifs qui sont mis en
place et face à ce contexte de de
tension et de crise nous nous place dans
une position où l'opposition politique
ne peut pas faire son
son travail de transformation sociale et
notamment ne peut pas
comment dirais-je
oui proposer une alternative politique
et notre rôle c'est quand même d'exercer
un contre-pouvoir et actuellement pour
le cas de notre association les
compliqués dans ces conditions là
d'exercer un contre-pouvoir et de
représenter l'ensemble du corps social
quand on ne peut même pas exercer notre
objet social
je vous remercie madame Marsault je vous
en prie merci monsieur le Président
merci beaucoup pour vos propos
extrêmement précis et je voudrais
rebondir justement sur l'expérience
d'ailleurs que vous citez comme tel et
qui transparaît effectivement dans vos
propos donc comme vous l'avez bien
compris c'est vrai que nous étudiants
dans cette commission
l'organisation la structuration pourrait
dire même l'histoire regarde des
précédentes auditions de ces
groupuscules ou mouvements violents je
les résumerai comme ça
ce qui se laisse ce qui laisse entendre
en tous les cas au bout de pas mal
maintenant d'auditions que le phénomène
est connu date de ne date pas d'hier
et et où pour résumer même s'il faut
faire attention évidemment au mot que
l'on que l'on que l'on utilise pour être
pour bien se faire comprendre où les
causes finalement sont des prétextes à
une violence
donc c'est un peu dans la ligne
d'ailleurs de la question monsieur le
rapporteur et de vos réponses mais
j'aimerais qu'on préciser un peu on nous
a même expliqué je fais une parenthèse
mais que par exemple dans les
manifestations
officielles on va dire autorisé
sans les forces de l'ordre les cortèges
n'avanceraient pas puisque maintenant
c'est c'est mouvement violent se mettent
en préortais
clairement dans la stratégie c'est
notamment le préfet de police de Paris
qui nous l'a dit voilà donc il y a quand
même ce jeu qui qui me semble un peu
connu donc que pensez-vous du fait que
ces mouvements violents se greffent
systématiquement ou quasiment
systématiquement sur des actions telles
que vous les définissez pour démontrer
par exemple qui a des alertes sur les
questions environnementales ou sur les
questions sociales pour faire connaître
vous vous rappelez vraiment votre
expérience en la matière donc moi ça
m'intéresse de savoir et puis une
question subsidiaire c'est est-ce que
pour vous
sans savoir si vous étiez ou pas ou
votre mouvement y était représenté c'est
pas ma question mais comment vous
regardez ce qui s'est passé à Sainte
Soline pour vous est-ce que c'était une
action de désobéissance civile du moins
au départ et sinon à la fin merci
je vous remercie là aussi monsieur gay
oui alors je crois que je ne pense je me
suis peut-être mal exprimé mais je crois
pas que les causes sont des prétextes à
des violences c'est-à-dire que les
poursuit oui bien sûr pour ces
mouvements je
oui bien entendu
il y a plein d'occasions de commettre
des dégradations etc bon là ça se fait
dans l'ordre de manifestations et donc
c'est pour moi c'est pas d'effet de
délinquance dans le sens classique de ce
qu'on entend par délinquance qui peut
effectivement passer par des
dégradations de bien ou ou d'attaque de
de personnes donc je crois pas que les
gens que vous désignez soit des gens qui
n'ont comme but dans la vie que d'être
violent vis-à-vis des forces de l'ordre
ou vis-à-vis des vitrines des banques et
y compris même si je ne partage pas
cette façon de faire être
commettre une action contre une banque
ou commettre une action contre les
forces de l'ordre qu'on le veuille ou
non c'est un acte politique c'est-à-dire
on peut ne pas être d'accord avec cet
acte politique mais il faut le
considérer comme tel voilà donc c'est
pour ça que je ne suis pas d'accord avec
ce constat de gens qui viendraient
uniquement se greffer sans raison sur
des sur des manifestations ensuite sur
le fait que là encore je sais pas ce que
vous a dit le préfet exactement mais si
les forces de l'ordre n'étaient pas là
les manifestations n'avanceraient pas
bon
maintenant qu'on a quand même quelques
années d'expérience des cortèges de
dettes en tout cas pour ce que je
connais de la de la région parisienne ça
se passe pas vraiment comme ça c'est à
dire que quand tu as ajouté était apparu
en 2016 il y a eu un module qui s'est
mis en place relativement rapidement
entre ce cortège de tête alors un
déterminé flou etc mais qui a avancé
quand même collectivement et les cordons
syndicaux bon et globalement on peut pas
dire que les problèmes ou les tensions
étaient très fortes alors on peut penser
que l'action des forces de l'ordre va
aider globalement ce qu'on voit
régulièrement c'est plutôt effectivement
des forces de l'ordre qui sont très très
proches des manifestants et qui créent
de l'attention et on voit la différence
et c'est une pratique on va dire on va
dire un propos assez courant parmi les
manifestants de se dire ah bah tiens
aujourd'hui alors on comprend pas
toujours les les pratiques de la
préfecture mais tiens aujourd'hui les
forces de l'or sont assez loin dans les
rues ça se passe bien c'est plutôt
détendu et puis à d'autres moments on va
avoir des manifestations qui sont
quasiment des nasmobile c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait les CRS sont en cours en
cercle tous les manifestants
devant derrière et sur les côtés et
marche de façon quand même extrêmement
enfin ça crée une tension extrêmement
forte donc je crois pas je crois pas
vraiment que les forces de l'ordre est
de
sauf quelques exceptions peut-être un
aide les manifestations à avancer
je regarderai
oui pour s'insoline vous demandiez
comment vous comment regarder qu'elle
regarde mon porte etc et notamment
est-ce que c'était une
un mouvement de désobéissance civile
donc c'est insoline à la base c'est une
manifestation qui a été déclarée et qui
ensuite été interdite donc c'est là où
vous parlez donc de désobéissance civile
mais ce qu'il faut s'interroger c'est
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle a été interdite
parce qu'on parle d'un de d'une
manifestation écologiste pour porter des
revendications pour le partage des
terres et de l'eau autour d'un d'un
trou de terre voilà donc il y a eu une
interdiction
vraisemblablement politique parce que
les motifs évoqués n'ont pas non pas
satisfait ce mouvement social écologiste
donc
c'est désobéissant parce que ça a été
interdit mais pourquoi est-ce que ça a
été interdit c'est plutôt la question
qu'il faut poser alors qu'on est dans
une urgence écologique telle et que le
sujet des méga bassines c'est un enjeu
vraiment fondamental sur l'avenir de la
gestion de l'eau pour pour la population
donc c'est plutôt pourquoi est-ce que ce
serait devenu une manifestation
désobéissante alors qu'elle aurait été
une manifestation tout court
je vous en prie oui mais justement mais
c'est plutôt aussi en lien avec ce que
vous disiez au départ sur les origines
et et de vos actions des actions de
désobéissance civile et donc est-ce que
pour vous la manifestation telle qu'elle
a été déclarée c'était justement une
forme de quelque part de désobéissance
civile pour justement fléchir ce que
vous disiez est-ce que c'était
l'intention de départ évidemment je
comprends votre réponse mais pour
fléchir quelque chose qui n'allait pas
donc vous c'était d'aller sur le terrain
pour montrer que des sites comme
celui-ci ça ne convenait pas à ceux qui
au-delà de la procédure de déclaration
vous voyez c'est mon idée
je comprends je comprends l'idée mais
sur c'était pour alerter une
manifestation le principe c'est porter
un message politique donc du coup là
c'était pour alerter sur le genre de ce
sujet notamment parce que ce sujet n'est
pas tranché puisque il y a des arrêtés
il y a des procédures en cours qui
interdisent des méga bassines il a des
procédures qui les autorisent donc
actuellement on est en train de
construire
la jurisprudence de ce sujet en fait
donc pour mobiliser sur la question
alerter sur la question la manifestation
à un moyen d'action et la portée aurait
été probablement différente si elle
avait été déclarée donc reconnu enfin si
elle avait été pas interdite et donc
reconnu comme légitime à exprimer un
message politique ce qui ne lui a pas
été permis
très bien
oui dernière dernière petite chose et
puis ensuite
toutes ces auditions qu'on a eu et
notamment évidemment de des forces de
l'ordre on nous a montré les armes dites
par destination j'ai appris aussi ce
terme et j'en ai vu par la première fois
de mon côté donc est-ce que vous pensez
que parce que ça a été interdit si je
vous entends
ceux qui sont arrivés et qui se sont
greffés c'est vrai que c'était mon
propos tout à l'heure c'est parce qu'ils
se sont parce que ça a été interdit qui
se sont greffés et qu'ils ont constitué
toutes ces armes par destination qu'on
nous a montré qui sont des armes on nous
les a prises en photo mais c'est quand
même
effectivement comment dire choquant j'ai
pas d'autres termes pour l'instant mais
vous voyez la relation de cause à effet
vous vous l'interpréteriez comme ça
déjà il faut savoir et vous pouvez le
retrouver sur divers sites militants que
cette les événements de sainte-solines
comme on les appelle aujourd'hui ont
on conduit à de nombreux débats qui se
poursuivent encore sur sur les modalités
d'action lors de weekend des 25 et 26
mars donc il y a pas de ligne qui
seraient unanime sur ces questions là
l'idée effectivement que des personnes
étaient mises en danger par telle ou
telle pratique et bien sûr questionner
bien sûr débattus et donc là dessus il
n'y a pas de tabou entre nous quand je
dis nous c'est l'ensemble des
protagonistes de ces de ces combats on
sait à la fois faire front quand il faut
le faire être solidaire avec les blessés
et en même temps effectivement débattre
de ce qui va ou ce qui va pas dans tel
ou telle chose après ce que je tiens à
dire quand même c'est que
peut-être que d'une certaine façon
il y a eu
sans vouloir être trop machiavélique un
piège tendu ou du moins une montée des
tensions depuis plusieurs mois et en
particulier dans les jours qui ont
précédé le 25 et le 26 mars de la part
de diverses autorités le mise de
l'Intérieur bien entendu la préfète des
nefs qui avait interdit plusieurs fois
les rassemblements les années
précédentes dans le sud des Deux-Sèvres
mais également une tension qui se vivait
près des populations locales
c'est-à-dire que c'est insoline c'est
pas très loin de la ville de Melle ou
c'est tenu le festival de l'eau pour le
week-end du 25 et 26 mars et qu'est-ce
que c'était que Mel une semaine dix
jours deux semaines avant c'était des
contrôles policiers en permanents des
ça me fait rire ce que c'est un peu
drôle des des jardiniers municipaux qui
sont privés là où ils travaillent parce
que ça a l'air d'être ça pourrait
devenir des appâts par par destination
des hélicoptères en permanence au dessus
de la ville bon tout ça ça légitime ou
qu'unement quelconque bien entendu mais
par contre ça participe du climat
ambiant qui a précédé de solides et le
dispositif policier je m'excuse mais
effectivement alors moi je l'estime pas
les attaques etc bien c'est pas ça mon
propos mais il était effectivement
comment dire une proie bizarrement
bizarrement organisé pour d'éventuelles
éléments que vous que que que vous
évoquez c'est à dire qu'on avait une
espèce de Fortin isolé alors le portant
en question c'était un énorme monticule
vide et puis une armada policière sur
armée tout autour alors effectivement
quand on est un militant qui
pour de bonnes ou de mauvaises raisons à
une certaine détestation de la police
bon voilà c'est sûr que ça fait bizarre
de voir ce paysage policier en pleine
campagne et je crois que là j'espère que
ça a été aussi discuté dans vos
précédentes auditions la politique du
maintien de l'ordre n'a pas été on va
dire des plus efficaces y compris en
termes de on va dire de stratégie de des
excès des escalade des tensions
je vous remercie donc Madame Yamamoto
monsieur gay merci beaucoup pour
l'échange que nous avons pu avoir donc
je vais me permettre de suspendre
pendant quelques instants le temps de
permettre à Madame la défenseur des
droits de venir nous rejoindre en tout
cas merci pour votre contribution
je